keilly suspected that when people
exercise longer their body temperatures
change she randomly assigned people to
exercise for 30 or 60 minutes then
measured their temperatures the 18
people who exercised for 30 minutes had
a mean temperature so this is the sample
mean for that sample of 18 folks of 38
point three degrees Celsius with a
standard deviation this is a sample
standard deviation for those 18 folks of
zero point two seven degrees Celsius the
24 people who exercised
sixty minutes had a mean temperature of
38 point nine degrees Celsius with a
standard deviation this once again these
are both sample means and sample
standard deviations of zero point two
nine degrees Celsius assume that the
conditions for inference have been met
and that Kylie will use the conservative
degrees of freedom from the smaller
sample size which of the following is a
90% confidence interval for the
difference in mean body temperature
after exercising for the two amounts of
time so pause this video and see if you
can figure it out alright now let's work
through this together so in previous
videos we talked about the general form
of our confidence interval our T
interval which we're going to use
because we're dealing with means and
we're dealing with the differences in
means and so our T interval is going to
have the form our difference between our
sample means so it could be the sample
mean for the 60 minute group minus the
sample mean for the 30 minute group plus
or minus our critical t-value
times our estimate of the sampling
distribution of the difference of the
sample means and that is going to be I
think have enough space here to do it
that is going to be the sample standard
deviation of the 60 minute group squared
over the sample size of the 60 minute
group plus the sample standard deviation
of the 30 minute group squared divided
by the sample size of the 30 minute
group and so we can actually figure out
all of these things so this is going to
be equal to the sample mean for the 60
minute group is thirty eight point nine
so it's thirty eight point nine minus
the sample mean for the
30 minute group which is 38.3 38.3 plus
or minus our critical t-value now how do
we figure that out well we can use our
90 percent confidence level that we care
about this 90% confidence interval but
if we're looking up things on a tea
table we also need to know our degrees
of freedom and it says here that Kylie
will use the conservative degrees of
freedom and that means that she will
look at each of those samples so one has
a sample size of 18 one has a sample
size of 24 which ever is lower she will
use one less than that as her degrees of
freedom 18 is clearly less lower than 24
so the degrees of freedom in this
situation is 18 or our 18 minus 1 so 17
and so using that and that we can now
look this up on a tea table so our
confidence level 90% and then our
degrees of freedom 17 so that is that
row the 90% confidence level is this
column and so that gives us our critical
T value of 1 point 7 4 so going back
here this is going to be plus or minus 1
point 7 4 times the square root times
the square root
what's our sample standard deviation for
the 60 minute group well they give it
right over here zero point two nine and
we're gonna have to square that divided
by the sample size for the 60 minute
group so let's see the 24 people who
exercised for 60 minutes so divided by
24 plus the sample standard deviation
for the 30 minute group so that's zero
point two seven zero point two seven
squared divided by the sample size for
the 30 minute group divided by 18 and
we're done and we can look down at the
choices let's see they all got the first
part the same because that's maybe the
most straightforward part thirty-eight
point thirty eight point nine minus
thirty eight point three plus or minus
one point seven four so both of these
are looking good we can rule out these
two because they have a different
critical T value now let's see we have
0.29 squared divided by 24 plus 0.2 7
squared divided by 18 this one is
looking good over here let's see they
mixed up our they put the 30 minute
sample size with the sample standard
deviation of the 60 minute group so that
won't work and so we like choice a